what's going on everybody welcome back
to another video today we're going to be
discussing the data analyst career path
more specifically we're going to be
talking about how to get the job so how
to become a data analyst and then where
do you go after that what are the steps
that you should be taking after you are
a data analyst to advance your career
even further now especially with number
one of how to get a job i have already
done a ton of videos on these subjects
if i've done a video on that already
i'll put a link right above my head so
you can click on it that will go a lot
more in depth into the subjects that
we're going to be talking about but
let's begin with number one of how to
become a data analyst before anybody can
become a data analyst the first thing
that they have to do on that career path
is actually learn the skills and so the
first thing that i want to talk about is
the skills that you need in order to
become a data analyst i think the three
biggest skills that are must haves are
sql excel and then tableau or power bi
or a data visualization tool some things
that would really help but may be a
little bit more challenging at first are
things like python or a cloud platform
like aws or azure but those things
typically come with time and experience
and so as you get further along in your
career you typically do pick those
things up as you go
learning these skills are typically the
very first thing that you have to do in
order to become a data analyst and the
very next thing that you have to do is
actually create a resume your resume is
basically a snapshot of who you are to
an employer or to somebody who might
hire you and so it is super important
that you get it right you want to make
sure that you portray yourself as
somebody that they want to hire and so
there are a few key things that you want
to remember when creating your resume
the very first thing is to highlight
your best skills if you are super good
at sql you should have sql listed at
least three times in your resume
probably in your summary in your skills
than in your job experience or a
portfolio project at the least next we
want to remove irrelevant jobs and
skills let's say for example you were a
chef for the past five years and now
you're trying to become a data analyst
for whatever reason you probably don't
want to showcase all of your skills that
you learned as a chef you want to now
focus on all the data analyst skills
that you've learned since then as you're
making that transition to becoming a
data analyst one caveat to this is if
you had a previous job that had a lot of
domain knowledge so let's say for
example you were a nurse for five years
a nurse doesn't have a lot of data
analyst experience but if you were going
to work at a healthcare analytics
company your nursing background may
actually be very useful lastly we want
to keep it neat and professional i see a
lot of resumes and a lot of the feedback
that i give is that their resumes are
not very modern they're sometimes stuck
in the 80s or 90s so having an updated
resume will really help another big
thing is i see people with either
headshots or really loud colors on their
resume and in general i just recommend
keeping it neat and toned down colors
like black and white next you're going
to want to create a portfolio a
portfolio is basically going to show an
employer what you're capable of the
skills that you have the process that
you take and what they will get if they
decide to hire you and typically i
recommend anywhere from two to five
projects and a lot of people ask me how
to actually create a project how do you
create a portfolio in general here are
the steps to creating a portfolio
project number one is actually getting a
data set or collecting your data so you
can either scrape data from the web or
you can go and get a data set from
something like kaggle or google next you
want to clean and transform the data so
that's usable later and you can either
do that through pandas in python or you
can do that in sql as well after you
clean your data if it's not already in
siegel i recommend putting it into sql
so you can build your views and show off
your sql abilities as well and then
you're going to connect your data
visualization tool to your view and then
you're going to create your
visualization now there are a lot of
variations that you can do in there with
collecting data the way you transform it
the way you actually visualize it but in
general that is kind of the basic
outline of how you create a portfolio
project and the very last thing is how
do you actually show your employer that
you have a portfolio well you can host
it either in github or you can create a
personal website and then i recommend
just putting the link in your resume now
the next thing that i personally
recommend is working with recruiters i
worked with a lot of recruiters to
actually get jobs and now i'm actually
working with recruiters in order to hire
people and so i see how valuable
recruiters actually are in the hiring
process and so i think that if you
haven't already should really think
about working with a recruiter and there
are really easy ways to do this the
first thing that you can do is actually
just set up a linkedin and linkedin is
really good because a lot of recruiters
look on there to hire people and to get
people in for interviews and so what you
can do on your linkedin profile is just
say that you are looking for jobs as a
data analyst or entry level data analyst
and have them reach out to you with
opportunities now if you don't feel like
waiting you can always call and email
recruiters i really recommend calling
first and actually talking to the
recruiter to let them know where you're
at and what you're looking for and so
when you send them your resume they can
at least associate you with that resume
maybe help you find a job a little bit
faster and lastly you're going to work
with recruiters to get interviews i
really think that working with
recruiters helps you get a lot more
interviews than just applying on your
own a lot of times these recruiters have
inside information or working directly
with companies and so the jobs that
they're looking for are ones that they
specifically know about and know if
you'd be a good fit for that position
the next thing is actually get the
interview and then eventually hopefully
get a job and so in order to do that i
highly recommend preparing for your
technical questions typically for
entry-level data analysts the technical
questions are mostly going to be on sql
at least that's what i found and then as
you get a little bit further along it
might be on python as well and you
should also prepare for those common
questions that are going to come up in
any interview one of the questions that
people mess up the most is what is my
greatest weakness it's just something
that apparently stumps everyone but is
asked in every single interview so i
highly recommend just writing down a
script so when you get asked that
question you have a really good response
and lastly you want to dress
professionally and be confident now it's
easier said than done for a lot of
people to be confident sometimes people
are nervous but i promise you confidence
goes a long way so just fake it for the
30 to 45 minutes that you're in that
interview so you've got the job you're a
data analyst and you've been in data
analyst for a few years now now what's
next what are the things that you should
be doing to advance your career after
that there are a few different paths and
we'll talk about each one after this but
something that every single person
should be doing is actually advancing
their skills and some of the things i
highly recommend learning are things
like python or r or you could learn etl
which is extract transform and load and
that's how you actually get the data
from the source into your warehouses or
into your databases and have listed some
options like ssis azure data factory and
aws glue which are some popular etl
tools you could also learn data modeling
you could learn predictive modeling and
analysis you could learn data
warehousing or you can venture into the
data scientist skills which is some of
the machine learning stuff and nlp which
are used a lot for data scientists now
once you've been a data analyst for a
while there are a few different paths
that you can take and one of these paths
is going back to school and this is a
really good option especially if you're
going back for a master's degree a
master's degree can really be beneficial
in your career long term and there are a
lot of degrees that are very relevant to
data analysts the first one being
computer science i think that is
probably the most popular one of the
most beneficial one that somebody can
get another degree is something like
information systems statistics there are
even data analyst degrees or data
science degrees now that you can get
that are very specifically geared
towards data analysts or data scientists
and so going back to school is a very
real option you can even do that while
you work a lot of people are doing
online especially during covid a lot of
people are doing online masters these
days and so it's becoming a lot less of
a stigma to actually get your masters
while you're working and so i highly
recommend that especially if your
company does tuition reimbursement or
they'll basically pay for your college
the next path is to just get promoted
and continue being a data analyst you
typically start at an entry level
position and then some positions that
you can get as you grow in your career
are things like a mid-level and senior
level data analyst which basically means
you're a data analyst but much more
skilled than a typical person just
starting out in the career the way that
that differs from a manager is a manager
is typically organizing the way people
do work in the most efficient way where
a lead or a principal data analyst is
typically doing all the work of a data
analyst but they have data analysts
under them that they help guide and
mentor but they also help them get their
work done so there's any blockers or
technical issues the lead data analysts
can help them get through those things
and as we mentioned earlier there's a
data analytics manager and typically
that person is not doing the grunt work
they're more on the managerial level
where they help decide what projects are
the most important and the ones that
will have the biggest impact on their
company and if you keep getting promoted
you might even be the director or the vp
of analytics which for a lot of people
is a huge goal and something that a lot
of people aspire to and basically this
is just a rundown of some of the jobs
that you might get if you continue to
get promoted as a data analyst and the
last path is actually pivot jobs as a
data analyst we work through a lot of
tools and a lot of softwares and so what
we do overlaps with a lot of different
jobs that you might be interested in so
take for example you really like the etl
side of things maybe you'll go and
become a data engineer but here are a
few of the jobs you might pivot to as a
data analyst something like a data
scientist a bi analyst a data engineer a
data architect a dba or a database
developer i plan on making a full video
about all these jobs and how you can
transition to them from a data analyst
to that position because as much as you
love being a data analyst there might be
a better job for you and for your career
long term now we will say that the path
of getting a higher education may
actually overlap with these other paths
because as you're getting an education
you can pivot jobs or use that degree to
pivot jobs or you can use that degree to
actually get promoted and make it all
the way up to that vp level but that is
all i've got for you today thank you
guys so much for watching i really
appreciate it if you haven't already be
sure to like and subscribe below and
i'll see in the next video